[Music]
welcome back to a careful boys and with
our special guest today gilbert jr yeah
gilbert jr
is that pretty accurate
making it cool again
[Music]
that's not bad yes it's not good either
that being said we have a couple prompts
and uh one of the ones that bart
suggested this morning what
don't put it on me
yeah let's put on bart you definitely i
have text message proof of this one you
said you wanted to know from all of us
that moment where we all knew how did
you know
when you weren't gay that's true you
guys know
like how did you know that's true that
you don't like boys
do you guys have confirmation because of
proof
proof of it i don't think i do evidence
now that you asked this prompt i'm like
i don't know if i do see i never really
questioned it maybe i just fall society
met with a woman and loved her but i
don't i actually love her i call that
laziness
you didn't find kind of [ __ ] up you
didn't find out you're gonna get married
too that's happening very soon didn't i
remember when i first realized i had a
crush i was in kindergarten and i met
this girl and i was like oh i like this
girl i like looking at her i got like
fuzzy feelings when i looked at her yeah
just [ __ ] stare at her
dude
you're
we're all creepy as [ __ ] kindergarten
huh your defaults
to be a creep i don't yeah i don't think
it's creepy when you're like a little
kid though but look i okay because
you're discovering [ __ ] right i don't
know because i remember i remember um i
really liked this girl we were in
different classes in kindergarten and
but we would share a recess together and
i really wanted to like talk to her and
then every time i saw i was so excited
and then one time i saw her and this boy
cuddling he was like squeezing her boobs
and her head and her face and i was just
waiting
do you fight him was squeezing her boobs
yeah they were just cuddling and she
sugar yeah we're just in the playground
and he was like squeezing her boobs her
shoulder her face and everything she was
[ __ ] snapped
head shoulder knees and boobs knees and
foot
she was he was wrapped around and then
like squeezing her like that and then i
was just like man that's my girlfriend
dude and i walked away and i walked away
you were the bigger man in that
situation yeah well at the same time it
was a only a one-way relationship
because i was like yeah she's my
girlfriend in my head i never talk is
that a thing like kindergarten pda i
don't think i even remember that
i was too afraid to even i remember guys
squeezing titties mostly
in kindergarten a big kindergarten
memory dude dude that's a wild memory
man
kindergarten that's pretty common yeah i
remember in first grade it was by the
nuclear power plant i remember in first
grade where um i thought that you got
chicks pregnant i thought the order was
you get chicks pregnant and then they're
yours
and so so in order to get them pregnant
you you do that through making out so
when everyone would leave when people
would leave from the lunch table to go
play i would go to everyone's high seas
and just slick it damn for what if you
got all of them pregnant that's what i
was hoping to do they all got mono
though i was hoping that i was going to
get all these chicks pregnant and they
would all be mine but it didn't
everyone's like it's all taste like
black vinegar
that is why my kids not going to public
school just because that's where you're
alone
oh jesus christ
because that's how they develop immunity
though you know what i mean yeah that's
true did you guys ever have like a best
[ __ ] friend though where like you
wanted to do everything together like
going pee together hang out together
whatever right and then um
like just it was like
that your friend was a guy
it could be mistaken as a gay
relationship but you're just like just
best buds you're just best buds yeah
yeah
which is very appropriate to the prompt
of how did you know when you weren't gay
when you're a kid it could you don't
know what's not a like i think anyone
could just think you're in a gay
relationship if you're a kid because
you're not trying to not look gay you're
just doing whatever
like you know when you're a kid you just
show your dick to like yeah yeah like
that's kind of gay but like but you know
that you know you don't know that yeah
yeah i just do it all the time and i was
fine and you don't have that intent
either yeah yeah
all the time wait what was what was the
context of you taking your dick out uh
so like during nap time in kindergarten
like what's the bit yeah this is the bit
and that time you're in kindergarten i
would go to the uh the boys bathroom
doorway where like only the kids could
see me and then just take my dick out
and just go whoa that's pretty funny
everyone loved him i guarantee everyone
everyone loves writing but like all the
guys were always [ __ ] laughing they
just when you're kidding my reactions
yeah so you have no correlation that
it's your dick out it's just you're
getting a laugh wait you guys i feel
like us three didn't do that because i
mean i don't know how you guys felt
about i think i was conscious of my
foreskin no bro that's how i knew i had
at the time too because everybody liked
peeing together
so then like take it back like i don't
know in kindergarten when it was
bathroom time everyone's liked peeing in
the same bowl or same same stall yeah
and then that's when you see other
people's dicks and you're like mine's
different
and then you start thinking like why is
mine so different well if you don't mind
somebody goes yours is different
i didn't really know about the whole
race thing until later on but then um a
lot of kids i remember going to the
bathroom and then we would do these
things called sprinklers so kids would
just drop their pants and then they'd
start speak peeing like this oh that's a
good time in a certain circle just all
over the bathroom they might yeah
before that his parents are like it's
not a great school system
it was horrible dude but
i remember when we would go and we're
peeing kids would come in and do
sprinkler on us so then they're on you
yeah so there's so so imagine the wall
right imagine that's the wall and we're
peeing like this right and then the kids
would come in imagine that the wall by
the way just for camera's sake and steve
where yeah yeah steve's the wall steve's
the wall street his mouth is a hurdle so
that's your child so that's the urinal
right and then the kids will be like oh
[ __ ] they'll run up right behind us and
start peeing in a circle like this and
all of us are like no
trying not to get caught that's pretty
funny though
but like when did it when did it start
like you know when you discover what gay
even is and then you just start to kind
of change what you do because you're
like well i don't want guys to think of
gays it's usually the first time when
someone makes fun of you for doing
something like that so gay even though
we don't know what game is you know
that's just bad it's like the fourth
grader when you're in second grade who
like just discovered it themselves from
their older brother yeah and then they
just perpetuate and repeat whatever they
their older brother said to you yeah
it's not even the word it's the tone
like oh that's so man yeah just like
what i don't want to be man yeah you
couldn't have any other way anyway
like i remember i didn't even know what
it was but
i remember uh the
i'm not gonna say it but it rhymes with
maggot okay and it starts with an f
right no saggit yeah he's dope
he wants
no but and i remember like hearing that
oh
and i just remember not knowing what it
meant but wanting to repeat it and then
so i'd repeat it by calling somebody
else that and then i got like [ __ ]
decked but i mean
other than that i think that same
concept applies where it's just like you
get made fun of and then that's how you
learn that that's not cool anymore
because you just don't want to be made
fun of again i think i used all those
words without even knowing what they
were because you learn it like
first or second grade and then you just
keep using it and then later you find
out oh it's it's actually guys love guys
and then some other kids be like no gay
means happy oh yeah dude i remember that
too and i was so almost like your
epidermis is showing i'm like oh my god
that's a little different though if you
go up in christian school like the idea
of you know like how do you know you're
not gay it's like well you're [ __ ]
taught you can't be gay oh that's true
you just treat them not allowed that's
true it's a different thing growing up i
think the first time i ever heard that
term like gay and all that stuff was
probably at a christian school in my
middle school well that was the first
time people would like throw it around
like casually and another thing in this
school that was thrown around very
casually as well was calling people no
calling people jews
these kids would call each other like
you're being a jew like they would say
like that if they're being stingy or
something just anything just like a like
a bad thing i just remember being like
so i went home then go to school in the
40s or [ __ ] it seemed like there's that
one eighth grader that's like hey i
caught everyone's shoes this looks like
juice it's a cool world from where i'm
from
i say juice my big brussel my big
brother talked to me
i don't know what that means they point
and say
i don't know mom picks them up it does
okay
it's time to go home
buy juice
goodbye
do you think the the temperature of like
conversations on school campuses today
with kids like is so different i mean
kids find out about gay education like
men earlier i think they're they're
better at maybe that's the worst
education we didn't have that yeah no we
didn't have that at all we had we had
avoidance yeah
do they use different words now though
dude i had a i had a dumbass teacher
well she wasn't a teacher she was like a
teacher's aide right
and then um we were waiting in line and
this kid kept calling me like a like a
chinese chinese and doing the whole eye
thing and i was like and i'm like oh
steve is laughing a lot huh and i'm like
i'm like i'm not chinese i'm like at
least say the right one i'm japanese
right yes and then the the teacher's
eight is like hey quiet settle down and
i'm like he won't stop calling me
chinese and then she's like
it's the same thing and then she walked
away she's like steve come to my office
steve green that's conflict resolution
right there right it's the safe to say
[ __ ] thing but like it's pepsi coke
who gives a [ __ ] yeah she was just like
it's the same thing and she walked away
and i'm like god even the adults in this
school are stupid
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about what you do not feel such as
anxiety stress and all this oh man
what's going on i got the jitters you
know why i drink a lot of caffeine
and sometimes i drink a little too much
when i have a lot of work to do because
it powers me out throughout the day but
what ends up happening is at night i
can't go to sleep and what happens i
sleep a little bit the next day i need
some more caffeine and thanks to fields
this actually helps me have an unwinding
routine where i put a few drops on the
tip of my
and then i start to chill i meditate i
relax and i fall right asleep and if
you're new to fields or you've never
tried cbd before they even have a
hotline which is really cool because
they can walk through the whole process
talk about how much you should take what
you're trying to get from it is it
stress and is it anxiety so you have
someone to hold your hand the whole way
through it's a natural way to help with
sleeplessness and all that stuff and
there's no hangover either so
you know it works pretty chill and they
even have a monthly subscription so it
makes self-care very easy and of course
they're going to hook you up with a
discount so if you get that you'll just
come every single month you get a little
discount and you have to worry about
ordering it anymore so if you want to
become a member today go to fields.com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's f e a l
s dot com slash off the record to get 50
percent off that's half
plus free shipping yeah and i was like
in third grade or something and i'm like
god man
kids just following you do the most
blatantly racist [ __ ] i know jesus
christ but that was normal back then
it's a different time yeah it was so
weird how everyone was just plainly
[ __ ] up racist homophobic and they
just did it to you i got called [ __ ] so
much i didn't even know it was korean i
thought it was filipino
because people people always call me
google i'm like i guess peop that's for
filipinos i think that's my name
he's like no it's ryan they told me but
i don't know i can call this along and
then the movie came out there's like no
filipinos
it took me 20 years so god justin john
i don't know but is there is there
education on that for uh like a
particular age today maybe it depends on
which school you're going to and all
that because
some places are more i guess progressive
and other places are more like you know
bible-y wait did you guys all grow up in
california pretty much yeah i don't even
remember people i was in georgia
and people didn't even they just they
never called me anything asian really
they never did this to you they did
maybe i just blocked it out and i think
about it did you feel more included or
you felt kind of but i simulated
pretty well that's why you wanted a
trucker hat and some [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
this guy
trump trump let's go let's go trump
trump trump
it's upside down dude yeah
the way he flipped it was cool yeah that
was dope um but yeah i remember maybe
like in my neighborhood i'd get called
buddha occasionally buddha buddha why
buddha or like fat some people just say
you start a fat mexican kid they would
just call you mexico they would say fat
mexican kid that mexican kid
is that like a casting director yeah fat
mexican come on
improv great
perfect okay go ahead you have 30
seconds just slate yeah
all right gilbert fat mexican kid
right before sleeping yes
greeting for peter parker
maybe i'll get his friend we'll see
i remember in high school those when i
started to see and interact with like
gay couples like like like they were
openly gay really yeah in high school in
high school there were um you know like
lesbian couples or like you know just
gay dudes holding hands and stuff and
like it was just a thing you know like
it wasn't it's probably not as accepted
and common as now because people will
still pick on them and like there'll be
some gay bastion but i remember it was
um there were some open gay people yeah
see that's one thing you you knew who
some of the guys were that were gay at
our high school but in georgia that's
not open you just go like oh we know oh
yeah yeah that's probably the
even the musical theater kid you're like
yo come on man but i'm stretched i'm
gonna play my vr game now
you know i i actually wanted to get into
dance in high school
uh and then my because my sister was on
the dance production team but they were
all girls on that team except for one
guy and that guy it wasn't open but it
was like everybody in the school always
just assumed and made fun of him and i
thought to myself
that if i were to join dance in any way
that people would feel or think the same
thing about me so i didn't dance in high
school wow yeah and that's why i started
in college because finally i went to
college and i started seeing these like
you know like guys and girls dance
together but it was cool and i'm like
that guy doesn't look super gay here at
all and all the girls are really hot are
[ __ ] all the guys that dance yeah
well that's like me and joe in high
school where like i would see
drama or theater
and probably majority of them are
straight
but
since all your friends call them the f
words
they're all f words and even though if
you want to do it then you're like oh i
don't want to be a f1 yeah just by
association yeah yeah that's one thing i
regret it has nothing to do with their
sexuality or anything i think i regret
that the most where it's like i'm so
afraid of being made fun of that i
didn't try a lot of artsy [ __ ] that i
was really i was like damn that looks
fun like the drama when they did the
performance in high school and all that
i was like damn that looks really fun
but then i i was like damn i don't want
them to like make fun of me because i'm
a hard thug you know
i think i hella benefited from because i
know there's a lot of parents out there
there's a lot of like advocacy groups
that are saying like i don't want like
gay agenda talk to my kids all this [ __ ]
but dude one of the best things that
happened to me was having a gay teacher
because you just you just see they're
not some scary thing that's like hiding
in the woods or some [ __ ] like it's
they're just a normal person just a
completely normal person like nothing
different about them so that was what
was great for me i think especially as a
young person it was like oh well you
know i see that that's not really a big
deal i don't know why you know it's a
lot of people who don't know yet it's
kind of like scary yeah has um like in
his preschool right now they'll have
like random days that they just get to
teach them stuff and on parent day
they're like some some parents are are
mommy and daddy some of them have two
daddies sometimes the like ones short
one's tall like you know it's like it's
it's really cool that like at such a
young age
it's just already taught to be like that
open and inclusive yeah so so did tyka
like see something like that and like
ask you questions about it or did you
guys have to no it's just the norm now
like it's it's like it just jumps past
it because i think it was like i guess
taught
or informed about so early yeah or just
the exposure is just there in like a
nonchalant way yeah like if we're at the
park and there are two dads it's he he
doesn't even question it it's just like
oh okay cool he's like lucky you got two
dads i know yeah mom's not bad
but that's probably what's gonna happen
she was like what the [ __ ] man
that's probably what's gonna happen
eventually you know what i think it's
gonna be tricky though oh i think for a
lot of parents that are struggling even
for kids i i think that even the trans
uh gender conversation is a trickier one
yeah because that's like so many things
you have to like that's tricky for
adults right now yeah so i think how do
you even but i feel like it's still
progressing though like i think slowly i
think we're in a the way kids talk about
it nowadays and the way they grow up
about it it just it is normal it is just
something like oh yeah like i have a
classmate that's bi or my classmate is
gay and it's like totally fine i have a
classmate that's trans and it's like
they understand the concepts obviously
like middle school maybe sometimes and
then even like high school like i use
coaching kids
who are entering high school now and
they have conversations about this and
they tell me like oh yeah i have a
classmate that's trans they understand
it and they kind of yeah that that girl
that's really important for like
especially your developing mind to be
like exposed quick because same thing
with me like the second i finally
had a gay friend and again this was
my first one that i knew about ended up
being all the way in college but the
second i had a gay friend is the second
i changed everything by understanding
about what it like a gay person was what
it meant to be homies with a gay person
you know what i mean or even like
hearing somebody else make fun of it in
a naive way and then being like yeah
that's actually not cool you know what
i'm saying so like if you don't have
earlier exposure then i'm guessing
you're going to develop a lot more
conclusions in your own mind that don't
make sense you know yeah there's always
people right now i think there's a lot
of people who are seeing like you know
when you when you turn on tv shows or
like you're watching commercials they're
like well there's just so much gay stuff
why is it always like it's like they're
attacking me with the gay stuff and it's
like bro it's just like a it's like a
reflex right now because we're making up
for a lot of lost time oh yeah we're
growing up all that [ __ ] was like
considered weird if you're a kid like
you're like oh i don't want to be seen
as weird don't please don't call me that
you know but now it's just it's kind of
like we gotta kind of make up for lost
time a little bit and like i think
everyone wants it to just be normal
where it's like who gives a [ __ ] and
that's how it should be because it's not
that long ago that even in you know
liberal cities you would have dudes just
roll up to gay guys and beat the [ __ ]
out of them that was that was still like
in the late 90s early 2000s
i remember watching that [ __ ] on the
news and being like a bunch of guys
rolled up on this gay couple and beat
them the [ __ ] up and then it's like dude
that was what less than 20 20 years ago
that's a that's very [ __ ] recent
because we remember that's when they
killed that kid matthew shepard too it's
like the same era they beat them to
death yeah yeah see and then it's like
it and it's like did people get amnesia
that this was it was even having these
conversations and even like gay people
just openly hanging out and all that
stuff that wasn't even a safe thing yeah
so that that [ __ ] blows my mind is like
why are people saying like ah we don't
need this you know there's too much dick
on camera or i don't know what they're
saying it's like who can who gives a
[ __ ] dude
yeah i don't know
yeah nick's been saying that a lot
actually i've been watching euphoria and
i'm like bro
yeah there's so many dicks on the show
actually
righteous gemstones yeah lots of penis a
lot of penises just filling that up with
a great show great show great shows
mainly because of the penis euphoria is
a great [ __ ] show it's so good but
it's too intense i have to like i can't
drink red bull while i'm watching
forever
he just got into shock but but that's a
good example though too right like all
the things that they talk about in like
euphoria i know it's like a newer show
but this is just mainstream now it's
like all these
these concepts that we used to think
were so crazy yeah are being shown with
high schoolers yeah so it's like norm
for them and it's a norm and it's a
really [ __ ] good show you know what's
so telling is that like i feel like kids
now like the whole like the gay jokes
were even like the dick jokes i don't
think they don't really do it as often
but you can really tell from our
generation even at this age in our 30s
we're still doing like gay jokes even my
gay friends in my age love the gay joke
yeah it's like our culture
it's our era yeah yeah
yeah it's nice that it's there's an
irony now though yeah like it's nice
that you're not actually scared of being
gay anymore yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
have gay friends i have gay best friends
and 20 years ago i was the one that beat
up those kids
i'm steve green that guy's name steve
it's my truth
say my name
do